two teenagers have been given life
sentences for murdering an Afghan Asylum
Seeker whom they had mistaken for a
member of a rival gang sixteen-year-old
rishmeet Singh had been walking home in
Southall in West London in November 2021
when he was chased down the road and
stabbed after tripping up rashmeet had
moved to the UK from Afghanistan in
October 2019 with his mother and
grandmother after his father was killed
by the Taliban venusian balakrishnan was
jailed for life with a minimum term of
24 years and Ilya Suleiman was will
serve at least 21 years the sentencing
judge described the impact of Richmond's
Richmond's murder
that had it had had on his mother and
grandmother
neither She nor her mother speak good
English
they were Reliant upon Rich meat for
communication
rishmeet was his mother's carer as she
is disabled by polio
they moved to Southall to be closer to
an afghan-seek community
with hindsight that decision to move
will haunt rishmeet's mother and
grandmother for the rest of their lives
with fresh meat's help they obtained a
flat
he was a vital and invaluable conduit in
all administrative tasks
Rish Meats showed all the signs of
growing into a valued member of society
he hoped to become a police officer
well after the sentencing rishmeet
Singh's mother spoke outside Court
um